i did all my own stunts and then we got
to do fight
training fight choreography and it was a
blast on set
cue the 2000's nostalgia it's time to
focus on the new film
we can be heroes that happens in the
same universe as the og superheroes
sharkboy and lavagirl
the filmmakers brought this franchise
into the 2020s with their magical cgi
skills
but we want to know how the movie would
actually look stripped of its visual
effects
every kid wonders how it feels to be as
big as a grown-up but actor leon daniels
got to experience it firsthand thanks to
the special effects
in we can be heroes his character
noodles has to use his stretching
abilities to make himself taller and
blend in with the rest of the adults
it looked so real on screen but
filmmaker robert rodriguez says
it was all done with an oversized jacket
that slid over his head
an expanding balloon on his chest and
lots of sound effects
simple two dollar trick while the kid
heroes are training for the battle they
get to fight this cool looking digital
villain that kind of reminds us of
katniss's time in the capitals training
center
but the actors actually had to pretend
that it was a hologram while filming
the scene it was really a stuntman
dressed in a green screen suit
they added in all the effects later on
if you're wondering if all the kids did
the majority of their stunts themselves
the answer is yes
calm down dear we caught a glimpse of
how powerful guppy was while she was
fighting the digital monster
she is the daughter of sharkboy and lava
girl after all
so how did they really bring her super
strength powers to life if we take a
look at these clips you'll see it
involved a lot of different cuts
stuntmen remembering choreography and
wires and just like that the actress
vivian blair turned into a superhuman
a very adorable superhuman have a nice
nap
this might have been one of the coolest
scenes in the whole movie on their
mission the kids have to climb up a few
flights of floating human stairs
yep human stairs casual there was a lot
put into this scene to make it come to
life the people you see floating were
actually laying down on platforms that
were edited out later on
and the kids were attached to wires to
keep them stable another tidbit is that
there were only three kids climbing at a
time
and in some instances the kids were
repeated as they got towards the top
their hair color was just changed
digitally later on to make them look
like the other characters
it was all an illusion it's about so
many layers
to make everything work
before captain marvel we had lava girl
and while actress taylor dooley is
iconic there were still some things she
needed
help with behind the scenes to make her
character truly come to life
flying plays a huge role in her
character and they accomplished this by
having her wear a harness and
controlling her with strings
and that epic scene where she blasts
from the volcano that was done using
not only a harness but a man in a green
screen suit moving her
and keeping her still and moments later
lava girl
blasted up from inside an active volcano
noodles powers might just be our
favorite we saw a glimpse of how they
brought them to the screen earlier with
him transforming into an adult but what
other techniques did they use
well noodles actor leon had to really
amp up his acting skills and act like
his arm or head was extending
they would then cut the scene and film
the other connecting the two in the
editing room
there's a reason they call it movie
magic
that's why i love making these kinds of
films
one of the main battle scenes is against
the aliens so how did they make the
aliens interactions with the heroes so
real
if you can take a look at this
comparison you'll see that the alien's
arms were actually wires attaching
themselves to the actors
who were pretending there was an actual
alien in front of them
then of course the visual effects made
everything of that more real
another part of the alien battle that
got pretty heated was when blinding fast
was using his super speed to confuse the
aliens
in the end it didn't go over well but
the special effects were still cool
they had his actor attached to someone
in a green screen suit who was guiding
him in circles
they sped it up in the editing room and
got a pretty impressive result
this is unbelievable
we saw the gist of how noodles powers
worked behind the scenes earlier
but how did they shoot this scene of
face maker flying
well it was actually done in three
different takes the first was noodle
hitting the blue ball
the second was a face maker being pulled
back while attached to a harness
and the third was a face maker swinging
from the rope that's what we would call
very smooth transitions red lightning
fury and crimson legend also had a major
encounter with the aliens
the scene of them being pulled through a
door by the aliens was so dramatic
we loved every second of it but while
filming the alien arms were just people
in green screen suits pulling them back
and the bricks they were fake and
probably made of something lightweight
like
styrofoam ladies i don't need today
[Music]
one of the closing scenes the parents
reuniting with their children
has to be the most heartwarming scene
can we take a moment to talk about how
adorable guppy and sharkboy were
but it was also demanding for the
editing team
and that's because there are so many
heroes using their powers at once
take a look at what the behind the
scenes of this moment looked like
i'm so very proud of
you there's a point in the movie when
acapella uses her powers
to make a room full of chairs float and
one of her fellow heroes climbs up on
one
it's actually pretty cool but if we
strip away all the movie magic
it's just a room full of people in green
suits holding up chairs
even the chair with the hero on it
welcome to a training round
[Music]
before the heroes kids took on the
aliens of course they had to practice on
a training ground
just like the reuniting scene this
moment was full of different powers
happening at once
basically the kids went through acting
the scene as if they had
actual powers then their powers were
added in later on
this is just an ode to how good these
little actors are okay
your turn what i'm not ready
we mentioned that the kids did a lot of
their own stunts throughout the film
and we thought this one was pretty
impressive there's a scene during battle
when wheels lifts himself out of his
wheelchair and does a handstand on
noodle's outstretched arm in order to
perfect this scene
they had to do two different takes in
order to get wheels lifted by his feet
onto a bar that would later become
noodle's arm
he's a miracle
ever wonder how a movie character
becomes a toaster in the blink of an eye
you're about to find out
basically heat vision acted really hard
and pretended he was using his powers to
turn
into a toaster then the director called
cut and someone placed a toaster in his
place
action pete vision's now a toaster
i love being a toaster you know i mean
you help people in the morning
we saw how they brought acapella's
powers to life when she was using them
on chairs but what about when she's
making herself float
well like lava girl it required a lot of
string and grace from the actress
that gave off the perfect ending of her
floating
what did you think of this behind the
scenes look will you be able to watch
the movie the same after witnessing how
it looked before it took a trip to the
editing room
we can be heroes definitely has some
impressive cgi and special effects going
for it
not to mention some unique techniques we
haven't even seen done before
tell us all your thoughts below don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
give this video a hero worthy thumbs up
we'll see you in another video
you